sisqó what happened everybody have
something you're gonna have to see
herself you're from before she dies
aren't you nice
tell me boost avatar we'll stop him
before you even try you're gonna be so
proud exclaiming sign down you're in for
a world of pain
all new episodes return Tuesday April
25th on the CW
happy Star Wars week everyone so you
requested a new flash video they drop
some new footage so I'll explain what's
going on and then I'll explain Star Wars
stuff that's happening the next couple
days at the end of the video there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
this will probably be like the last big
flash video before a weekend of Star
Wars bombs being dropped so there'll be
a bunch of Star Wars that I'll explain
at the end of the video but the new
stuff in this is that they confirm that
both mirror master in top or back in the
future
they're like the de-facto rogue leaders
of the city in the way that captain cold
and heatwave used to rule Central City
so I know everybody's wondering which
roads are coming back next season the
legends of tomorrow stuff sort of put
them on the sidelines so they're just
putting forth mere master is the new
person to rise to the top of the pile
top sort of comes with him I'm not a big
fan of the costume she's wearing in this
but I do like the dynamic between them
the top himself was a really weird
character in the comics really silly so
there's really no way to do it in a
hardcore serious way so I do like the
performance that she's giving but it is
a little weird it was fun to see her be
a villain for Jessie quick and you have
to imagine that while this is all
happening Jessie quick is having her own
adventures on earth 3 because she's
filling in for Jay Garrick right now -
yes going back to her - I three actually
you just got here Jess I know I know and
I want to be with you I just have a
purse that he had plans for me in the
future I can't let that happen
so I've been told variation chat Jana
the Speed Force
her story needs a flash to protect it we
can talk about Jay Garrick in a future
video because we'll come back around to
him eventually but he's kind of sitting
on ice in the Speed Force right now you
guys can let me know how long you think
it's going to be before they directly go
back to see him or do you think the way
all the way to the finale or do you
think it'll happen right before then
usually by the time they get to the
finale they've wrapped up all the big
storylines of the season and they're
starting to tee up what's happening next
season so whatever's going on with Jay
Garrick all the background storylines
most of those should be wrapped up by
the time we get to episode 23 so when
you see her giving Barry all this for
that's our version of Barry not the
future flash version of Barry and I like
the way they jump from emo Barry to
future flash costumes so you're like
wait wait a minute does like future
Barry get his [ __ ] together what's going
on it doesn't make any sense
what it seems like is happening is that
the flash is still the flash in the
future because we've see the costume but
team flash has completely fractured so
like Cisco's off on his own killer frost
is off doing killer frosting and we
actually got confirmation on whose hand
this is when she's scraping the site I
think they just made a better version of
the trailer with better CG so you can
actually tell so this is her scraping
her hand across here I saw a little
confusion in the comments on the last
trailer video people thought that iris
might still be alive like wait so you
get a look at her like maybe she just
gets maimed what they're saying is she
ends up dying they fail to find a
solution so that's what Barry's going to
be doing for the next couple of episodes
as he travels into the future still no
confirmation on who this future
scientist is where she's working she's
just somebody that's going to help Barry
when he goes to the future a lot of you
are wondering if she might be the Julie
Grier person who replaces iris as the
byline on this newspaper I don't think
that's the case because a journalist
that works for the newspaper would be
writing this and when they cast this
actress they said that she would be a
scientist so she'd be more like Harrison
wells or Tina McGee somebody working on
something more advanced that could
potentially give Barry help that he
can't get from other people in his
current time and yes the day that he
travels to in the future is the same day
on the future newspaper flash vanishes
in crisis so there is a connection there
but that's talking about the future
flash not about our version of Barry
so whatever Barry does in episode 19 it
directly leads to this crisis happening
but hopefully that gets them one step
closer to saving iris and I know a lot
of you have been messaging me with
pictures and behind-the-scenes stuff
they've finishing filming the finale
right now Kid Flash just wrapped his
last scene he posted this picture with
the goggles those are just Cisco's
goggles that he's wearing but he's doing
a funny kid blast joke is like hey Young
Justice Kid Flash so they could always
do that in the future but this is the
actor just having fun it's not like
they've completely changed his costume
or they're doing a Young Justice thing
and I'll talk about Young Justice in a
separate video
because the actor that plays Aqualad
so that he was going in to record
dialogue for season three but it's going
to take them a long time to finish that
series a lot of you asked me about what
the deal with kid flashes if Barry was
able to get his back broken by zoom and
he can walk again the Speed Force healed
him
why can't Wally do it well maybe because
saboteur took the Speed Force from him
or cut him off somehow or somehow he was
damaged beyond repair there's been a
couple things on legends of tomorrow
reverse flash teases that there is
future technology that's capable of
killing speedsters cutting them off from
the Speed Force just weapons that are
very deadly for speedsters so there's
any number of ways to explain how he got
hurt and can't fix himself but I don't
think that they're going a hunter
zolomon route because that's what
happened with him he got his back broken
bike rod then he used the cosmic
treadmill to try and go back in time and
prevent the accident and that's what
turned him into the zoom character in
the comics but obviously very different
from what the TV show did so please do
not post super spoilery
behind-the-scenes stuff from the finale
in the comments there were so many
people being weird when I posted that
Deathstroke video even though Marc
Guggenheim the showrunner himself said
welcome back Manu and they said the
Deathstroke was coming back there's just
a lot of exciting stuff happening in the
flash finale in the arrow finale and
even Superman is coming back on
Supergirl during their finale
so everybody is ending the season with
this huge bang if they make official
announcements about stuff then I'll do
videos about it but I try to avoid like
super spoilery stuff from behind the
scenes but the actor that plays avatar
did confirm that he in fact is the
person that's underneath all the suits
the makeup so that could mean a number
of different things it's this actor here
so all that confirms is that it's not
one of these other actors that's
actually wearing all that stuff but
typically they put somebody else under
the costume and they change the voice a
little bit so that when they do pull the
mask off on-screen it can be some big
twist so all the stuff that's been
posting recently really only blows about
half of the Sabbat are theories out of
the water so just wait a couple more
episodes before you lock in to any
particular sabotage theory but what's
happening with Star Wars Celebration is
that there's a big 40th anniversary
panel I'll post that later today if
there's any teasers or any footage all
that to tomorrow's the big last Jedi
panel there's going to be footage for
that what happened to ja ja spoiler
alert he did go to the darkside have a
great time everyone may the force be
with you
men especially with you always take care
of course I'll do videos for all that
stuff both will be panels footage
behind-the-scenes posting for like the
next three or four days I'll probably
take through Monday to post it all so
I'll try to get as much stuff as
possible but leave all your requests for
videos in the comments below so right
after I post this it'll probably be like
an hour - then I'll post my first big
Star Wars Celebration video it's going
to be an awesome weekend you can follow
me here on social just to find out what
videos I'm working on or make requests
for specific videos but I'll try to do
as many things as possible
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Griffin Keely please private
message me so I can get your contact
details so while you wait for new Star
Wars Celebration you can click here to
learn all about future villains
happening on the flash and you can click
here for brand new Star Wars thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you